President Trump has pledged to do
whatever it takes to pressure Iran to
halt what he calls malign conduct
punishing new sanctions aimed at
quashing the Islamic Republicans
republics rather nuclear ambitions as
well as missile programs and influence
in the Middle East go into effect next
week
Elizabeth Palmer's reporting from Iran's
capital Tehran where Iranians are
struggling with a weak economy good
morning today is a religious occasion in
Iran it's a day of mourning in the
Shiite religion and it reflects the mood
of the country in general that is somber
ever since the United States pulled out
of the nuclear deal in May sanctions
have begun to bite here President Trump
says he has no quarrel with the Iranian
people but they are the ones who are
already suffering their currency has
plummeted and foreign companies and
investment is leaving the country at the
expense of thousands of jobs and the
worst is yet to come the most punishing
round of sanctions sets out to cut Iran
off from most international banking and
crucially stop it selling its lifeblood
oil we've spoken to people here who are
so despairing they're planning on
leaving in the country all together but
the millions who are staying behind are
frustrated and angry of course with
their own government for its
inefficiency and corruption but also
with what they see as a bullying and
belligerent United States for CBS this
morning
I'm Elizabeth Palmer in Tehran